today we'll be diagnosing performance
issues using Google cloud trace cloud
trace helps you find slow requests and
shows you where time is spent in your
application its trace analysis feature
allows you to see latency distribution
for your application and find those
painfully slow requests that may affect
only a few of your users to get started
with cloud trace we visit the projects
page in the developers console select
monitoring traces settings and turn
traces on cloud trace has very little
overhead so you can safely leave tracing
on in production
once traces are enabled cloud race will
start sampling requests received by your
application and continue to do so as you
deploy new versions of the application
now we'll select the trace list tab to
view the latest traces for our
application we'll use a search filter
setting the read book URI we can also
select the HTTP method status or
application module version and the time
range for our search we will take a look
at this top one you'll notice that
clicking on an element will reveal
information about that request you can
also view the log for the request to
return to the trace details click on the
response time link in the first row this
simple navigation between logs and
traces makes it easier to debug
performance issues now we'll create a
trace analysis report comparing two sets
of traces click on new report we can
specify at the request URI method status
we can give the name some criteria last
24 hours in this case create a
comparison which also specifies module
version and time range once the filter
is complete we click on submit to
request the report let's take a little
bit of time to happen so we will click
on it already prepared report in this
report the big blue bulge in the center
of the graph clearly shows the latency
of the requests for today is worse than
set B yesterday you can also see that a
small blue bulge in the far right
showing deterioration in the long tail
latency you can also see a cumulative
distribution the table below the graph
show
the percentile agencies for sets a and B
you can see that set a has higher
latency than B for every displayed
percentile the table also shows samples
traces for each percentile for example
you can click on this sample trace at
the 90 percentile to take a look in this
video we've seen how to set up Google
Cloud trace view and filter recent
traces and create a report to look at
our overall performance cloud trace is a
great tool to help you monitor and
improve your application latencies thank
you for viewing this screencast you'll
find additional information at our
webpage cloud google.com slash tools
slash cloud - trace please ask questions
on Stack Overflow tag Google Cloud trace